das ist wirklich ein phänomenaler crash
zweier ungleicher partner ende april
konnten die lage und würde observatorien
ein gravitationswellen signal empfangen
das wirklich ungewöhnlich ist mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit handelt es sich dabei
um die verschmelzung eines schwarzen
lochs mit einem neutronenstern und das
wäre wirklich eine absolute premiere
denn solch ein crash konnte bislang noch
nachgewiesen werden und das ist nicht
das einzig merkwürdige signal dass
astronomen und astronomen jetzt den weg
tieren kommt ein klick zum tanzen
fiction
hier gibt's täglich spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasste nichts herzlich willkommen
astronomie teams haben das ereignis
hashtag es 19 04 26 c getauft die
dazugehörigen gravitationswellen trafen
am 26 april 2009 10 um 17 uhr 22 unserer
zeit ein und ihre form ist wirklich
ungewöhnlich wie die fachleute über
twitter bekannt gaben handelt es sich
bei diesem ereignis höchstwahrscheinlich
um die verschmelzung eines
neutronensterns mit einem schwarzen loch
wenn das durch weitere analysen
bestätigt wird während das tatsächlich
der erste nachweis einer solchen
kollision bisher wurde solch ein crash
nämlich nur theoretisch vorhergesagt was
dabei passiert ist wirklich
beeindruckend denn ein doppelsternsystem
das aus einem extrem massereichen stern
und einem leichteren partner besteht
erreicht hierbei das ende seines
lebenszyklus der schwere stern wird in
der super nova zum schwarzen loch der
leichtere partner wird zum
neutronenstern wenn ihre orbitz eng sind
nähern sie sich zunächst an
dann kommt es zu einer verschmelzung das
ist wirklich ein tolles tanz ungleicher
partner noch ganz sicher sind sich die
fachleute des laser interferometer
gravitationswellen observatoriums kurz
lego in livingston in den usa und des
französisch-italienischen
gravitationswellen detektors irgendwo
noch nicht der grund das eingefangene
signal ist relativ schwach und die
quelle konnte bislang noch nicht ganz
eindeutig identifiziert werden
doch die beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind optimistisch dass es sich
tatsächlich um ein
das ereignis handelt und nicht bloß um
irdische störsignale laut den experten
und expertinnen ist es derzeit aber auch
noch nicht ausgeschlossen dass das
ereignis steckt es 19 04 26 c
gegebenenfalls aus einer
neutronensternen kollision stammt und
eben nicht aus einer ungleichen
kollision eines neutronensterns mit
einem schwarzen loch falls sie mit ihren
vermutungen aber recht behalten
liegt seine wahrscheinliche quelle rund
1,2 milliarden lichtjahre von uns
entfernt
und zwar in der nördlichen himmels
hemisphäre und so sind astronomie teams
weltweit mit hochdruck dabei den
ausgangsort dieser gravitationswellen
aufzuspüren doch dem nicht genug auch
der tag davor hatte es in sich die
leitung korrelation twitterte dazu eine
aufregende und schlaflose nacht für
viele astronomen rund um den globus denn
auch am 25 april 2019 liefen
ungewöhnliche signale ein und zwar um 10
uhr 18 unserer zeit dabei handelt es
sich nach ansicht der experten und
expertinnen wohl mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit um die
gravitationswellen die ford einer
neutronenstern kollision stammen das
wäre dann überhaupt das zweite mal dass
eine solche kollision nachgewiesen
werden konnte
dieses ereignis wurde auf den namen
hashtag essen 19 04 25 cent gekauft doch
auch hier sind die signale noch nicht
mit 100 prozentiger sicherheit zu
interpretieren und das aus einem
ärgerlichen grund denn als diese wellen
liefen war einer der leiter und
detektoren auf klein und so läuft auch
hier in fahndung nach dem strahlen
ausbruch den diese neutronensternen
kollision verursacht haben müsste auf
hochtouren den ersten berechnungen
zufolge könnte diese kollision in rund
500 millionen lichtjahren entfernung
stattgefunden haben und nicht nur solche
höchst aufregenden meldungen wie diese
beiden aktuellen sind super spannend
sondern tatsächlich die gesamte
geschichte rund um die
gravitationswellen wir haben ja hier bei
klick zum science fiction immer wieder
über die neuesten erkenntnisse berichtet
ganze 100 jahre nach dem einband 1 stand
die existenz der gravitationswellen
vorhergesagt habe kam es nämlich erst zu
einem ersten nachweis 2017 ging dann
sogar der nobelpreis für physik an drei
amerikanische gravitations werden
forscher denn sie hatten mit ihren
experimenten und mit ihrer
grundlagenforschung zum ersten mal den
nachweis von gramm
aktionszellen erbracht insgesamt konnten
14 solche ereignisse bis heute
registriert werden unter anderem durch
die gravitationswellen observatorien
lego und wirkung die messungen laufen
hier in einem sogenannten interferenz
experiment bei dem ein laserstrahl in
zwei teil strahlen aufgespalten wird die
lichtwellen werden in zwei röhren
geleitet die exakt gleich lang sind und
senkrecht aufeinander stehen also im
rechten winkel
am ende steht ein spiegel der sie
reflektiert und zurückwirft wenn sich
die strahlen im normalfall aufheben gibt
es kein signal kann jedoch also durch
die interferenz löschen sich die signale
aus kann jedoch ein signal gemessen
werden liegt dies an einer
gravitationswellen die die raumzeit
verzerrt denn dadurch variiert die länge
der röhren das große problem hierbei ist
allerdings dass die messung sehr genau
sein müssen da der effekt der
gravitationswellen extrem gering ist
anfang des jahres wurden erst vier
aktuelle neuzugänge verkündet die durch
die kollisionen von schwarzen löchern
entstanden waren unter den neuzugängen
war auch ein echter rekord brecher mit
dem namen g w 17 07 29 die massereichste
und am weit entferntes der
gravitationswellen quelle die bislang
überhaupt aufgespürt werden konnte knapp
5 sonnenmassen wurden bei dieser
verschmelzung die wohl vor etwa fünf
milliarden jahren stattgefunden haben
muss in gravitationswellen umgewandelt
wodurch diese ganz spannenden einzel
entdeckung lässt sich nun stück für
stück ein gesamtbild zusammensetzen und
die fachwelt ist optimistisch dass schon
in kürze weitere spannende entdeckungen
folgen denn dazu schien von der
university of glasgow
die wissenschaft hat ein jahrhundert
gebraucht um einsteins vorhersagen zu
bestätigen doch das tempo unserer
entdeckung hat sich seitdem enorm
beschleunigt und nochmal richtig geil
erklärt gibt es gravitationswellen hier
draufklicken anschauen und 100 sekunden
physik abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran